from a distance this may not look like a  village  but get up close and you'll see it's a  small settlement built into the hardened  debris of an erupted volcano  located in the northwest corner of iran  is the ancient village of kandovan  these unusual looking peaks were created  when now dormant volcano mount sahan  erupted thousands of years ago  over time the volcanic ash lava and  debris hardened to stone and the unique  shapes are the result of weathering  inside the peaks are livable caves that  have been turned into homes by the local  villagers  surprisingly they are some of the most  economical on earth the cave's  insulation means no heating or cooling  is required  there's also a mosque a public bath and  a school  the term candovon is derived from the  persian word cando meaning beehives  and fittingly 600 people call these  hives their humble home  [Music]  you